le droit de vote des étrangers c'est un
feuilleton qui a commencé il ya près de
20 ans françois mitterrand est élu
président de la république dans les 110
propositions du candidat l'article 81
prévoit le droit de vote des immigrés
aux élections municipales
après cinq ans de présence sur le
territoire
le projet va nourrir le discours de
l'extrême droite et son ascension
électorale françois mitterrand en fait
un cheval de bataille la participation
de ces immigrés à la gestion locale
me paraître une revendication
fondamentale qu'il faudra réaliser sept
ans plus tard nouvelle présidentielle
jacques chirac présente à sa manière le
programme socialiste
pour les migrations
le retour au laxisme des années 81 85
avec en plus le droit de vote donnée aux
étrangers l'extrême droite surf sur
cette polémique et décroche plus de
quatre millions et demi de voix au
premier tour de la présidentielle
deux ans plus tard en mai 90 le ps
renonce à son projet
des obstacles d'ordre psychologique dix
ans on est encore passée les municipales
de 2001 se profile le projet qu'on
croyait enterrée ressurgit jean pierre
chevènement fait même un pas en avant je
crois qu'il s'agit pas de ressusciter je
ne sais quel brûlot
s'agit de
ne pas laisser s'instaurer une injustice
mais lionel jospin et les socialistes
hésitent à relancer le débat avant une
élection pourtant à droite chez
quelques-uns l'idée a fait son chemin
c'est très simple pratiquement tous les
maires que je connais sont pour le vote
aux élections municipales des résidents
étrangers dans leur ville depuis un
certain temps l'extrême droite
mégrétistes manifesté hier encore contre
le droit de vote des étrangers après
vingt ans de polémique le débat peine à
trouver la sérénité
alors et élargissons de débord avec un
tour d'europe dans l'europe des quinze
le droit de vote des étrangers ne fait
pas l'unanimité précision tout d'abord
depuis 1992 les ressortissants de
l'union européenne peuvent voter aux
élections européennes et municipales
mais il faut distinguer trois groupes de
pays concernant le droit de vote des
étrangers non manque de pays de l'union
européenne vous allez voir sur cette
carte en vert on trouve notamment le
royaume uni l'irlande et les pays
scandinaves les pays bas la cwa pour le
droit de vote en orange où l'on
reconnaîtra le
l'italie l'allemagne le il est aussi
l'espagne par exemple c'est sous
conditions et puis en rouge pour
l'instant ces noms comme la france et en
grèce et pour comprendre comment cela se
passe dans un pays qui a déjà intégré ce
droit de vote des étrangers voici le
reportage de philippe boisserie valérie
lucas amsterdam aux pays-bas depuis 85
les étrangers peuvent voter mais
également se faire élire
la scène peut paraître extraordinaire
aux pays bas elle est d'une totale
banalité la commission économique du
conseil municipal d'amsterdam a rendez
vous avec la direction de l'aéroport
pour discuter privatisation parmi les
conseillers municipaux
l'un est d'origine marocaine un autre
ghanéens et ce n'est que la couleur
politique qui décide de la place de
chacun à droite comme à gauche tout le
monde a choisi la carte de l'intégration
abdellatif chéri be est l'un des onze
conseillers municipaux étrangers sur les
45 élus d'amsterdam un chiffre
équivalent à la population immigrée de
la ville élu depuis six ans abdellatif
chez reavie se refuse à jouer les porte
drapeaux je ne suis pas le porte parole
des marocains ou de tueur je suis le
porte-parole de la population le terrain
et le fait d'origine marocaine que je
suis d'origine marocaine me donne un
point d'avancé sur mes collègues
néerlandais parce que je comprends mieux
un certain de nombre de problèmes de la
population marocaine dans cette ville le
sentiment communautaire voir le repli à
des latif chez reavie le connaît bien
lui qui travaille par ailleurs dans un
quartier en difficulté d'utrecht ici pas
de ghetto néerlandais étranger qu existe
dans la rue comme dans les urnes
je pense que c'est normal car s'ils
payent les mêmes mots les mêmes taxes
ils doivent savoir aussi le même
c'est vraiment important de donner son
opinion sur la politique parce que vous
vivez ici et que beaucoup vont rester
ici mais les toasts à la
trop lente émergence d'élite issus de
l'immigration l'échec scolaire la petite
délinquance des problèmes perdurent si
le droit de vote n'est pas tout il est
jugé comme un outil d'intégration
important ça ne suffit pas l'éducation
ou branco beaucoup plus important mais
pour l'honneur et le sentiment deux
étrangers qu'on appartient tout à fait à
un certain vu une certaine ville où un
certain village ou à un butin que les
droits de votes très importants comme
symbole au début des années 90 un parti
extrémiste a vu le jour aux pays bas il
a largement contribué à mobiliser des
électeurs étrangers au départ filet et
c'est par les urnes que ce parti a été
depuis chasser des principales
institutions du pays
[Musique]